hey guys Ryan Wright here and I'm
finally gonna watch the trailer for this
signal can't remember who but some guys
been asking me to watch it over and over
again for like the past 18 months and so
here I am finally about to watch the
signal still the notes about I think the
wrong fish bun is in this film and
Laurence Fishburne is cool man he's
awesome
that's great thing he did was like 10
years ago and that was the matrix
probably older than 10 years ago
actually that's still a kick-ass movie I
know kung foo can you tell you I'll
guess Nicholas Eastman are you from
Earth yes I'm from Earth
what I'm about to tell you Nick you may
find it disturbing
due to circumstances surrounding your
condition I'm afraid that our
information is extremely limited
beautiful condition where was my
condition
she's [ __ ] cute
oh what a cool shot can you recall for
me the first time you encountered the
signal what what is the signal what is
the matrix
let's go or not you're not a hundred
percent certain about what we're doing
no neither am I
to Nazi war camp are you gonna tell me I
need to return your what oh she's a girl
from Bates Motel wrote Laurence
Fishburne where's that suit this whole
movie
what the [ __ ] is going on
it looks really cool
whoa sounds like it nope I got big teeth
I love a good sci-fi movie man
I love trailers like that trailers that
don't give away too much like the
amazing spider-man 2 it's like something
that is like teasing the tone kind of
teasing the idea about it but you're
still unsure it's like it's one of those
trailers that really hooks you in and
goes I want to know more about this
you're lying so thank you for
recommending that to me I really want to
check that out and you know it's like
it's one of those sci-fi movies that's
not overblown good [ __ ] but it is just
enough sci-fi but it's grounded at the
same time at least it looks grounded I'm
not sure it's just straight but still
I'm gonna check it out on Laurence
Fishburne he's still cool I guess that
girl she's cute I wanna kiss her any of
you guys if you're new to the channel
subscribe
the hell's going on want to give us some
shoutouts Josh Jenner Jenner said he'll
buy me in and out in and out man [ __ ]
they have a thing they're called a
secret menu that's not secretive if you
haven't heard of the secret menu get
some animal style french fries they are
to die for
Oh God in and out is delicious you know
why it does well because it's called in
and out
well thanks Josh gainer now you gonna
buy me in and out [ __ ] was my in
and out [ __ ] destination noob here's
what he said vile truck you down get a
laptop smack it in your face and shove
your camera do and throw and come out
your butt you know what man I'd like to
see you try and if you didn't that would
be very impressive
I had clap I wouldn't be hurt I want to
be offended and I'd be like well done
dirt man your work usual feed I like
that name usual feed some hungry that in
and out talk I'm he's so hungry right
now the usual feed that's cool what is
it like a transcendent kind of thing are
you a computer feed usual so what your
average come on man
don't call yourself average remember you
are unique that's why I like to say the
word unique begins with the letter U so
don't conform for the usual don't be
average go out there make something of
yourself
but listen to your parents and get a
degree buck your dreams I'm getting
usual feed go after whatever you want to
do this is wrong if I consider paying
for a hooker